chris cope bootleg head podcast
you know what i came to do huh
[ __ ] i got stripes like foot locker at
the finish line this fall of crime out
and did but never did the time you gonna
get a face shot
anytime you mention mine pipes is busted
it's texas up in the wintertime
hallelujah i'm rocking with all the
shooters i up it imma use it
turn murder the music goon the gang
going stupid you trust us you was
foolish saint weezy on the lick he came
back speaking jewish
loyalties get influenced by soldiers
they stay the truest the blood talking
numbers i know it speak it fluid the
vices is behind us i give them daily
reminders either sell all of that
or you getting stuck with china know
some real old timers said never mind the
comments give a [ __ ] with that money and
trust me imma find it i never need a
homie for a homicide assignment fast
forward with the foolish you made me go
rewind it number one up in the game like
devin i get defined
posted up with the rock i'm feeling
close to the plot got my partner in the
valley he watching over the crop
and the kids caused a bitcoin come and
purchase some stock i ain't worried
about cops
unloading until it's hot reloading spin
the block [ __ ] with a big bottle
trying to give me some time but i told
her be cool my baby mama got a glock
tail birdie cold flock put together a
killer crew sniffing coke i'm selling
you knowing what the filling do the
mirror looked at me and said nobody
really shoot
none inside that [ __ ] weave she act
like it's gorilla glue name a villain
who
doper than me i burn the guns and the
pills over rolling the g
i nicknamed the pistol child cause the
[ __ ] ain't sweet and if that [ __ ] set
him up he getting smoked in the sleep
yes i'm strolling not creep hoes norm
complete that's why your [ __ ] trying to
get
bent over the seat don't ever call me
about beef you better handle your own
me and my uncle's so rocks like frank
and jerome i was
getting some dome on the satellite phone
know a few little [ __ ] man that
i broke
i go inside your house give a [ __ ] if
you're home i used to drive the birds
now them [ __ ] get flown
it's 20 21 center hit the withdrawal me
and the [ __ ] [ __ ] never
getting along
you gonna make fox 10 you this christ in
this song and the bar is so raw you can
sniff on the song yeah
coke that is from the west side [ __ ] i
know i'm the [ __ ] best there is
coming out my city where them dope boys
live double up on the soda and invest
that quick
14 years old he had a new black switch
and a drum hell 50 but he shot 26
i'm 32 for life i'm not gonna flip i'm
mashing blunts on them [ __ ] from the
top where i sit
more like time break just like tom brady
throw a bullet down this field if you
won't complain me i'm invested in that
white [ __ ] like drake did shady
count money sell fish i'm on the same
ship daily terminator with the check
the matrix made me how the [ __ ] you go
comparing with ain't nobody comparing
these [ __ ] it's bigger than the
rallies they wearing
and you're about to get shot if your
homie keeps staring yeah
check the city ain't a cook like coke we
gon drive it we gon fly we gon put it on
boats
put a slug up in his throat if he said
[ __ ] coke turn that boy asthmatic
he want no smoke put his homie in the
blunt then stomp on the ropes
[ __ ] that getting close [ __ ] you getting
shot on approach told her [ __ ] i got
snow she tried right on the slopes
don't tic tac me cause you could die for
a joke [ __ ] them